liberal celebrity is now backtracking
after calling for Trump donors in
Hollywood to be outed Will and Grace
star's Debra Messing and Eric McCormack
walking back their controversial
comments and claiming they were quote
misinterpreted McCormack posting on
social media that he doesn't support
blacklist or discrimination of any kind
and Messing retweeted the statement
saying I couldn't have said it better
alright Michael so you have worked in
Hollywood for a long time you know a lot
of celebrities were you surprised to see
backlash by people on the left toward
these comments by Whoopi Goldberg for
example who's not a conservative and
others I thought what thank goodness for
Whoopi Goldberg
I completely agree with what she said
because there's no way that Eric
McCormack was misquoted he said exactly
what he thought give me a list of the
people going so i know who i don't want
to work with and Debra Messing was right
there to back him up it was really
terrifying it was really terrifying but
all his ate all he's guilty of is saying
something that Hollywood's thinking you
know and just not saying out loud this
is probably the end of my Hollywood
career right after this I'll be washing
Gutfeld car okay it's great no it was
it's really scary and and there's
there's this big like rah-rah in
Hollywood who look how much I hate Trump
look I hate everyone who supports Donald
Trump and it's it's not a good comment
because then they're the cool kid look
at me man I hate him it's it's yeah it's
like throwing rocks at a at a building
and breaking windows look at me I
destroyed something now their claim one
is that they're saying well we just want
transparency we're just trying to bring
transparency to the process but that's
not what Eric McCormack said I mean he
said quote so the rest of us can be
clear about who we don't want to work
with but I thought about transparency
I would agree I think that that was
over-the-line and I think that's why you
see him getting called out but
transparency Jedidiah is important I
mean what the Supreme Court said I guess
that citizens united and that doehner
case was that political donations are
the equivalent of free speech well if
it's free speech let us hear you we want
to hear who's saying what and what you
have to say I mean that's why when you
saw as a Joaquin Castro say you know
here's a list of Trump donors oh the
right and the Trump people got so upset
and then Steve Ross got upset when
people said here here's a list of the
people with Steve Ross is inviting from
$250,000 to a Trump fundraising event
but guess what if that's what you're
doing what's so secret why shouldn't
Americans know where political IDs wrong
because the left wingers are crazy and
they'll probably salt these people who I
caught them or blacklist them cuz that's
exactly what this whole thing well the
right has been right because the right
does not owe your boycott or do any of
that stuff um this is what's going on a
Hollywood permission to stereotype an
entire industry they're extremely
coddled their child like they've never
been told no and they have a team around
them telling them that everything
they're doing is noble and righteous so
when they go out and do something like
this and saying let's blacklist our
fellow actors and actresses our own
neighbors their team finally gets around
them and they says guys this is trashy
you can't do that so it's like a child
getting slapped down and then they have
to walk it back the walk back was no
because it's very clear what he
explained it's like someone steals your
bike you catch them and then the guy
says I was just borrowing it together
you were I saw you're unlocking it and
racing in the other direction but you
know they gotta learn their lesson
because a lot of these people are just
you know they don't really know a lot
about the news and about what they're
talking about and they're very easily
exposed see I'm just glad that this is
happening openly because for so many
years this this blacklist thing and all
this stuff happened behind closed doors
and they didn't reveal that now they've
you know these celebrities feel
empowered to put it right front and
center good point it's a very good point
it's also Twitter for as much as we
complain about it has exposed a lot of
people because Twitter is free speech it
doesn't make it smart speech and so it
like I said yesterday this just always
gives Trump another man in the game he's
just like oh okay I'll take another one
I'll take another one because when you
have your handlers every going like oh
oh boy even like you guys shouldn't say
that you're just helping him that's
probably not what they set out to do
I think they were miss under interpreted
should be a word
so Michael do you think this is gonna
get worse or better or worse is it gonna
get to a point where celebrities realize
that if there's backlash within their
side and liberals coming out and saying
hold on this is not a good idea we don't
support it is it gonna stop no well the
tweeting may stop it'll just become more
secretive you know everyone used to walk
around in hushed tones you know you
never admit you voted for Trump you
never admit you lean to the right and
and Hollywood should be full of like
libertarians it's the it's the most
capitalistic foul the American dream it
always kills me when these when these
Hollywood people like like Jim Carrey is
always like halfway socialist now it's
like dude you came to America with
nothing but the clothes on your back you
worked really hard you've had you had a
skill and a whole lot of luck and look
at that you've achieved something and to
have these people like turn their back
on the American dream it's just it's
it's sad but it is the reality because
dumb and dumber was probably one of the
all-time great comedies in the industry
and then he goes and ruins it I don't
think he again Jesse the Joe McCarthy
era and blacklisting was done by people
who identified with the right in this
yeah that's why nobody doesn't anyway
that's why they shouldn't do it that's
why the communist sympathisers remember
they remember what happened to all
McCarthy have you no dignity
okay so isn't it ironic that they're now
pulling a reverse makar that's why
people on the Left are saying this is
the wrong thing to do okay we need more
people on the left all right